hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play Octodad
now I've since calmed down from my
previous venture and I will no longer be
panicking in whatever I do so let's see
whatever games they have here that I can
totally throw around
aren't these Mellinger I only got to get
four of these okay I'll try this one
here excuse me lady I I just need to get
a good grip on it with my groin get four
that can't be too hard huh hey I got two
hey I got four did I win it said only to
get four I got six is that good am i
doing good am i doing good mr. eels I
just want a gentle I guess I'm done now
I'm gonna go on my way hello my lovely
wife I got you this pretty pretty eel
for you to cherish for the rest of our
life
oh sorry lady extinct you a little bit
no don't get what baby the ocean but you
seem to hate the aquarium well of course
Fisher dirty dankey stupid little
animals yeah I'm just gonna go over here
sir would you like to challenge me in a
game of I haven't even started yet but
I'm playing some serious defense if I
could just get up here if I could just
get up here if I could just get up here
how about you just cooperate there we go
oh really you're just gonna flop her out
ya know games are for children yes so
what were you talking about you really
not I cannot no no you're wrong I'm sure
yeah
nah man Tessa
we don't have rules where I come from
the word you're gonna embarrass me like
this over and over again well I say no I
say no sir
I say no rap when it's by another yeah
we're born to play basketball yeah hey
uh how come that guy hasn't come up for
air uh what are you talking about man I
honestly have no idea what you're
talking about I am just a perfectly
normal human shot our lady right Boop on
your head take it thank you remember
when we were taking that cake decorating
class no after that bakery burned down I
had a lot of questions to answer why I
don't have any idea why the bakery would
have burned down I'm just gonna take
this prize back lady appreciate it go
over here and blast someone huh oh of
course
turtles can have you ever seen the
pokémons how many do I have to I have to
blast 20 fruit how's it oh god it's
inverted oh god this is a communist
turtle it's inverted Oh God
come on blast a damn fruit get that belt
come on come on come on come on I'm out
of time I'll get the damn road no rewind
that never happened hey yeah this is
definitely the first time I ever did
this one I definitely didn't shuck major
donkey balls when I was doing this
before unlike that I'm doing now which
is obviously much these controls don't
make any sense that they have to do they
really have to make everything
impossible to control you gotta be
kidding me no no no no no no rewind
definitely the first time I've ever done
this one again also for the first time I
would love to get more than one in a row
oh look how good I am
well the practice I've never had all the
times I've never done this they're all
coming back to me now
the past lives that I've lived not
wasting time doing this stupid thing
alright get yeah that's right I got your
number now maybe I don't ya
I did it I did it everyone and on the
first try on the first try I managed to
do that you're welcome you're welcome
for that amazing performance everyone ha
no I do not want that again
I'd really don't want that basketball
IRA
fine you know what there we go just
wanted to show my skills off a little
bit
hello lady just wanted to pump my
growing up a bit just a little bit doing
a little dance for you you like that
baby
you like that you like that dance baby
oh yeah oh yeah sorry got a little
excited there take it take it lady musty
old basement you mean my mancave
see I appreciate it lady that's really
awfully kind of you
damn to go play some basketball get six
uh nope ah no ah no no not at all screw
this I'm getting up there
ha yes we take forever otherwise wow man
you work for to play basketball thank
you I know you like the way that I crest
this thing over here the hoop the where
I score my goal units and score a lot of
home runs okay i think i block my yeah I
seem to van a secret oh you were born to
play basketball oh oh I know oh I know I
know so very much I know stop stop what
what you don't like it stop what stop
what mister stop what big boy you'll say
it to my face
you'll say those to my face buddy what
are you looking at say that to my giant
eyeball looking at you right in the face
or I'll go get that or I'll just venture
on over here
yep and there we go
new thank you I'm about to alert
everyone to my predicament yeah throw it
away baby this one's even better
you're welcome so when we're talking
about us you clam up
yeah clam up that's a good one I'm gonna
go laugh about it over here ha ha ha how
do I win this one all right or rather
how do I cheat it this one uh okay okay
yeah I wanted the one way deep in there
you know the one that's the hardest to
get that's how I am
how about how about a bow ski yeah baby
I suddenly got good at all these games
isn't it amazing everyone now I just got
it
oh no not not what I wanted thank you
sir please excuse me as I go deliver
this to my lady you sorry did you get
hurt madam Oh No the tank is sprung a
leak
hey my hands are full why don't you try
to fix that instead isn't that a bit of
a more problem than that I could never
mind you know what I'm going for you
baby cuz I am the best yeah kids you
might want to run away really fast oh
wow
Oh Oh No okay well thanks lady really
are you kidding me you're gonna go over
there and criticize me as I'm trying to
save the entire aquarium
oh really don't drown oh wait a minute
is that what they were saying about me
coming up for air is that what was
really going on what do you mean who how
is that what are you talking about
homeboy
how much but no get it get it get it get
it get it get it get it get it
when these piranhas be eating me alive
at this point really really lady
I just saved everyone in this aquarium
including the fishies and that's all you
have to say to me that is really all you
have to say to me baby fine be that way
I'm going on my own
I'm gonna go see my son the one who
actually respects me
but suspiciously looks a lot like the
mailman all right time to go see
wherever the hell my son went was that
my daughter hey Stacy come over here I
want to pet you humans like that being
petted come back here ah fine there's a
shark tank okay not time for that
perfect whoo no no no no no no no no
just a normal human being
grinding on shark teeth hey mister shark
you want to dance you saw what I did to
that tank up there
you wanna look mocchi you want to see my
moons baby oh yeah oh you're much better
than the tank
what say we being creepy I just want me
okay I'm gonna go over here
you don't be weird just like I'm not
being weird and we go be old that old
behold Oh what man look at all this
money come on dad
let's get through all this junk so we
can get out yeah exactly kid what is a
stupidity what am I supposed to do help
how fast can you map the world's kelp
forests um now that big globe and I'll
get the quiz going what are you talking
the kid I do not want to do that kid kid
don't call me a slug call me a man go
dad go what um what what do you want me
to do what exactly am I supposed to do
here
I alright good kid we're learning it's
fun to learn it's fun to learn things
with horrible controls wait oh I get it
this more than one it's over there it's
over there it's come to my garage spin
it as hard as I can it's really hard
that I can spin it kid I've gotten good
at splitting things my dude had that I
had that come on oh this game was more
charming when they didn't just come up
with frustrating things to do jump it
and then there's one on the bottom on
the bottom you get back here you [ __ ]
you get back here [ __ ] you get back
here [ __ ]
I got it yeah everybody who got it
everyone be cool I got it that was so
much fun it's so much fun to learn it's
so much fun to have fun and learn
alright yeah let's go have fun so much
fun
can't believe how much fun I'm having
yay dad you got to make that slide at
home that long I don't think I can don't
what am i doing now kid what have you
got for me what's in store now this
glowing can of what I can't even move it
kid you expect me to actually do
something oh my okay
all right that's that's really cool
that's really cool kid what the hell are
we doing I do not even know HAP I think
I'm oh yeah yep yes exactly that you
take your green balls you shove them
into a ladies blue balls and then you go
around and make babies that's exactly
how it works kid you're so smart that's
why you're my most beloved son of all my
80,000 children take a tilt quiz boy it
sure would help if I knew where the
Tilted quiz was to find out okay but
what the hell's sports Johnson
I'm okay secret kid IM sports Johnson in
addition to a loving dad oh yeah yeah
exactly kid yeah of course
okay all right I'll try baby ah come on
Oh get get get get it get it get it baby
yeah alright I am running faster I am
sports Johnson oh my god that is the
most ridiculous thing I've ever seen my
huh did why huh did you get any out here
kid thank you thank you for being the
biggest dick oh okay the top of the Celt
to find out okay how do i touch the top
of the Cal uh oh it's right there I
would love to touch it
hip yep you almost got it got it yeah oh
no I've seem to be flying like a pretty
little butter okay never mind
well I'll sure lived was try that agree
hahaha yeah oh I'm so beautiful for
watching oh no fine whatever
chupa dope did appeal oh did you just
push that kid oh thank you so much son
who is you where do you be do we
yay
okay the urchins eat kelp and otters eat
sea urchins good I guess save Kel from
urgent extinction what just try and
attack those kelp dad what does that
even mean what am I trying to do okay
what am i doing okay oh I get it
oh I see oh my god uh all right kid yeah
you're amazing
whatever yeah oh come on come on
all right that's right kid the best
otter in the world you're welcome you're
welcome kelp I'm gonna help you who
responsibly okay what is that hey it's
me hey it's me oh my god you're king of
the octopus is that a good thing to be I
don't even know I don't know where's
your sense of douchiness oh I see you
found it and everyone else's and you're
also kind of a prick that's okay you're
my son I love you and whatever no no no
no no okay how do i oh that's how I do
that I know you remember here we go
we're back on track back in it to win it
I don't think any of that is real kid
but you go on with your imagination if
you really want it I want that tie yeah
baby
got a tie I'm the grease dad yeah son I
really care about reverse skiing right
now if you put your mind to it you could
do anything you wanted Hey
you jolnir Oh burn up oh shut up lady
you're lucky to get my ink on you
no no rabbit no no oh god please please
please please please please like what
are you doing with your leg what are you
doing and I had it under control the
whole time thank you
kid are you throwing things at me I may
have to kill you I may just have to
strain your liver through your eyeballs
how about I just put it on the damn
platform thank you very much
no no no there we go no no and there we
go okay no okay there we go all right
all right all right
Wow Wow bad no it's okay think of the
kids think of the kids just think of the
cake let's just keep the kids in line
it's gonna be okay think of the kids
it's gonna be okay okay yay how do I let
my dude ah okay all right whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa ease on up for a
second there how the [ __ ] know but know
something you dick
oh do something no nuh-uh yeah yes No
oh come on that middle one's cracked
that middle one's crack no no no no
please please please please please
please please please no no no no no no
huh I am so happy to have beaten back it
certainly was a challenge the
perseverance of the human spirit burns
within me good job son
I learned a lot too yeah I'm literally
sweating you can see a thick layer of
sweat okay I'm gonna go die so hope you
all enjoyed that my voice is now
permanently gone forever and I'll see
you in the next video things are just
things are really really really good
mother Oh God flip you son of a [ __ ]
I'm gonna kill you god dammit man [ __ ] I
don't wanna pick her